il a une forme de chaleur ou de canaux
c'est le pid et
le pid et c'est quand même bateau mais
très très minces la porte est
extrêmement mince christian et
c'est le les garnitures dessus le pid et
est à la turquie ce que la pizza et l
italie
maisons de pisé dans chaque point de vue
on en mange
tout le temps donc il n'y a pas d'odeur
le manger pdt aussi comme quand on ne
déménage ici on commande la pizza fine
ou en commande de fini
puisqu'une prépare deux variations
classique de pid et une la viande et
l'autre au fromage
traditionnellement il ya la viande
hachée avec triumph in their tomates
piments des fois les pauvres
le fromage feta ricotta ou d'autres
sortes de fromages de la région
je prépare la ricotta on la farce le
fromage dépit des
c'est sûr que ça peut faire fusion cette
oreille un seul filet mais c'est quand
même beaucoup dorion d'un ratio devient
en fait sont retrouvés moitié moitié ça
c'est le veau haché je vais acheter un
peu de chemin
les gens ressentent dans le persil le
sambal oelek comme un fait alors ton
passé je m'abstiens pu chasser la farce
comme quand tu étais petit oui c'est
exactement ça quand j'étais petit
j'emmenais ça c'est sûr que là on était
une famille de cinq
[ __ ] gros voire aller chez monsieur py
dit qu'ils lui avaient la part il
faisait cuire avec votre futur porte
avec mes bras en guise d'amusé bouche où
exactement
ah ah mon dieu j'avais j'avais presque
oublié ce sentiment
au mythe ou tiare est originaire de la
région de konya en turquie le pi dès
qu'il appelle bateau sur son menu le
rattache lui aussi à son pays natal je
sais a commencé à l'âge de 13 ans je
vends les corps et quand c'est le
coltiner 3 1 ap 3 je vois les
restaurants pour apprentis les fidèles
à son arrivée à montréal il ouvre le
tout premier restaurant dédié au pid et
dont il se fait une fierté de préserver
les noms dans la langue d'origine
ça ouvre sa federer poulet et suzhou
soudou que c'était spécial tube romain
sorti ce matin par 106 une dizaine de
variétés de pid et sont préparés sur
commande chaque jour
[Musique]
rappel nous quels sont les finisseurs
utiliser un seul si j'ai seulement et
persil j'ai ajouté un peu de
si vous l'êtes aussi
[Musique]
mais dans le fromage maples un dock de
deuil à percer la nes ciboulette et trop
macho
je prépare la pâte quelques jours avant
pour que ça soit bien bien le lac ce
qu'est ce que ça fait là partent quand
il fait le flip sur terre mais ouais
c'est comme pour une façon de pétri
sans appuyer dessus les lieux m le y ont
voient même pas la main c'est comme ça
qu'ils font je vois qu'à chaque fois tu
le fais la pac c'est avec ça la porte
est important la chaleur de four est
important enfin la façon de le faire
le pi des camps pour moi gagner on
tourne un peu les boules puis si on
utilise une garniture plus
fragiles comme les pizzas seulement les
verdures comme l'épinard bêta car ce
genre le plat on trouve carrément
il est possible de faire cueillir son
pide à la maison dans un four chauffé à
son maximum si on fait dans le four
c'est mieux de chauffer une plaque qui
claquent avance ou une si on a une
pierre à pizza ça va aider aussi parce
que là ce qui est le plus important
d'avoir la chaleur qui viennent de fonds
pc c'est très faisable sur les barbecues
des sorties du four le pid et et burry
est tranchée au morceau qu'on mange avec
les mêmes jeux vous offrir un morceau ok
[Musique]
bonjour tellement bon
l'aparté légère de croustillant pas
sèche
la farce est superbe
[Musique]